und wir wollen weiter diskutieren mit
CSU-Generalsekretär Markus Blume der uns
jetzt zugeschaltet ist guten Morgen Herr
Blume hallo
ich grüße sie grüß Gott hallo Herr Blume
wir alle hatten uns doch darauf
eingestellt 60 70% der Bevölkerung
müssen geimpft sein und dann kriegen wir
endlich die Freiheit wieder und jetzt
sagt er gestern die Bundeskanzlerin ich
musste selbst ablesen die zielimpfquote
von 90% bei den über 60-Jährigen und 85%
bei den 12 bis 59-Jährigen das sind
immer neue Werte da fühlt man sich doch
veräppelt wie soll das weitergehen
es ist leider so dass Corona immer neue
und häufig auch negative Überraschungen
für uns bereithält wir sehen dass bei
den neuen Varianten der Impfschutz nicht
so ausgeprägt ist wie das am Anfang der
Fall war und deswegen ist das impfziel
jetzt ein höheres gleichzeitig ist
impfen der einzige Weg zur Normalität
und deswegen kann ich dringend nur an
alle appellieren dass wir uns
gemeinschaftlich in Deutschland hier auf
den Weg machen für mich ist impfen ein
Akt der Solidarität und ja auch gerade
zu patriotische Pflicht nur so können
wir sicherstellen dass wir in künftigen
Wellen eben keine Beschränkungen mehr
brauchen ich bin im übrigen auch der
Meinung dass wenn jeder ein impfangebot
hatte und das auch wahrnehmen konnte und
vollen Impfschutz hat dass dann die
umfassende Fürsorgepflicht des Staates
ein Stück weit endet und vor allem dann
auch wieder Eigenverantwortung gilt und
trotzdem letzter Satz müssen wir schauen
dass wir unser Gesundheitssystem nicht
auch in künftigen wählen an die
Belastungsgrenze führen deswegen bis wir
das Ziel erreicht haben es sind die
grundlegenden corona-regeln weiterhin
wichtig dennoch setzen wir ja man hat
das Gefühl die Ziele so hoch dass man
fast schon jetzt schon eine recht
fertigt um dann eventuell im Herbst
Winter wieder alles dicht zu machen 85
Prozent jetzt diese neue Zahl im Raum
das können wir doch gar nicht erreichen
impfen ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
wir müssen schneller durchgeimpft sein
als die nächste Welle heranrollt das ist
unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe und da kann
jeder einen Dienst auch für seine
Mitmenschen leisten es gibt Menschen die
aus verschiedenen Gründen sich nicht
impfen lassen können weil es eine
Indikation gibt die dagegen spricht umso
wichtiger ist dass alle anderen die sich
impfen lassen können dass auch tun wir
haben deswegen in Bayern jetzt dafür
gesorgt dass so niederschwellig wie noch
nie geimpft werden kann man kann den
Impfzentren ohne Termin gehen man kann
quasi an der Supermarktkasse am
Parkplatz bei der Sportveranstaltung
geimpft werden also impfen wird so
einfach sein wie noch nie und insofern
appellieren wir auch an jeden dieses
einfache impfangebot tatsächlich zu
nutzen schließen Sie denn aus dass es
irgendwann mal dann doch wenn es nicht
so vorangeht wie geplant eine
Impfpflicht in Deutschland geben wird
eine Impfpflicht war bei uns nicht das
Thema und sie wird nicht das Thema sein
ich appelliere an die kollektive
Vernunft der deutschen dass jeder weiß
was notwendig ist wir alle wünschen uns
nicht sehnlicher als Normalität und
volle Freiheit das Impfen ist das Ticket
dazu
und wenn die Vernunft uns da nicht
weiterbringt auch die Kanzlerin blieb ja
da gestern so ein bisschen schwurbelig
und sagte im Augenblick appelliert man
so an die Vernunft was ist denn wenn die
Vernunft uns nicht aushilft
es ist eine klare Hierarchie Anreize wir
müssen jetzt alles tun als gehen vor
Pflicht wir müssen jetzt alles tun dass
die Anreize so groß sind dass dann auch
tatsächlich sich möglichst viele impfen
lassen eine Impfpflicht ist in anderen
Ländern nur die ultima ratio ich gehe
davon aus und hoffe dass wir so etwas
bei uns nicht brauchen
sie gehen davon aus sie hoffen das
klingt aber zumindest nicht danach dass
sie es auch völlig ausschließen können
diese ultima ratio Blume vielen
herzlichen Dank dass Sie sich Zeit
genommen haben für dieses Gespräch gerne
mehr Nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei Bild schau dir hier das nächste
Video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren